on va
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir
que l' aventure ce soir pour nicolas et
pimprenelle
partir sur un nuage au patron la
première fois que je suis monté et que
j'ai volé sur notre nuage j'ai eu
tellement peur nos deux petits amis sont
beaucoup plus courageux que toi et puis
notre nuage vol très très bien le temps
est bon notre voyage sera rapide je vous
fais confiance
patron vous en connaissez un bout en
météo vous bon les châles je vais
chercher pimprenelle et nicolas
et aux hommes peu pom pom pom pom pom
boy
est ce que je mets ma casquette sur la
tête dans la valise dans la valise
nicolas elles pourraient s'envoler avec
le vent et bien bravo je vois que vous
êtes heureux oui mais papa reprenait et
que fait elle elle se fiche les filles
font toujours les attendre
bon on t'attend je peux fermer la valise
oui
j'ai pas oublié ma chemise et mes
pantoufles et this ans j'ai déjà regardé
et ton pyjama nicolas il y annonce ya
même une surprise pour caen michon s'est
trop gentil alors fermons
la
saluer pape rhône elle nous sommes prêts
j'aimais celle ci bien c'est ma alors ça
y est
voilà ça y est
tu es très élégant pas preneur
j'ai mis un foulard autour de moi
vous avez bien fait il ne s'agit pas que
vous preniez froid dans le ciel alors on
s'en va ou quoi en avant
[Musique]
à
vous voilà les enfants dans ce petit
marchand de sable bonsoir nikon a un bon
soir comprenait lé alors patron on s'en
rend oui nounours vous êtes près des
enfants vous n'avez pas peur moi j'ai
jamais peur
ils sont courageux le voyage ne sera pas
long une petite heure pas plus chic
alors on va faire de la vitesse en route
bonnut les enfants allez vite vous
coucher soyez bien sache les fêtes bourg
[Musique]